hi everyone sal khan here welcome to the
homeroom live stream we have a really
exciting guest today pedro noguera who
is the dean of the rossier school of
education at university of southern
california so
start thinking of your questions putting
them on the message board on youtube or
facebook wherever you're watching this
and we're going to try to get as many
questions as possible to dean nogueira
about all things education higher
education what's going on in k-12 i
think all of that is fair grain whatever
is of interest to you
before we jump into that conversation
i'll give my standard announcements uh
first of all a reminder that khan
academy is a not-for-profit organization
we uh only exist through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about making a donation at khan
academy dot org slash donate i also want
to give a special shout out to several
organizations that stepped up uh when
covid hit and we saw that our costs had
gone up because we were seeing 250
percent of normal usage and we were
trying to accelerate a whole series of
programs
so special thanks to bank for america
google.org att fastly novartis and the
many other funders at all levels
including many of y'all uh for helping
keep khan academy going uh we continue
to need your help so once again if
you're in a position to do so please
think about making a donation uh last
but not least reminder for everyone
about homeroom with sal the podcast uh
wherever you can find your podcast it's
an audio version of some of the
highlights from
this live stream that you can consume
safely in your car so encourage you to
check that out so with that i'm excited
to introduce
pedro nogueira dean of the roster school
of education at usc pedro thanks for
joining us
thanks for having me sal great to be
with you
so there is a ton to talk about maybe
the best place to start i mean i want to
talk about you know given you're in
higher education but you're in higher
education at the school of education i
think you have a really interesting lens
on both higher education and k-12
big picture
where do you think we are on the covet
crisis in education uh you know is what
what's going to be the main damage done
and what are the big opportunities
wow so so much damage um we just
released a report today uh from usc
showing
the impact of virtual learning on kids
just in la area and
there are still thousands of kids who
have you know uneven or real total lack
of access to virtual learning and that's
not been corrected and i'm not fault in
the district because they did and have
gone to great lengths to get screens to
kids and to connect with the internet
but um we still have lots of communities
across the country uh particularly in
rural areas but urban areas as well
where there's no internet service um so
it starts there there's just no access
then we have the fact that there are you
know as we know many affluent people are
able to put their kids
into learning pods they get higher
private tutors they're independent
schools where kids are coming back um
that's not happening for kids who are
dependent on the public schools
especially in um our low-income
districts so the disparities that were
there before the uh the the pandemic are
going to be worse after
and
i guess two questions is there anything
we can do to help
mitigate some of that damage or if we're
not how do we deal with it once we we do
normalize whatever that might be
well you know i i start by just
reminding the viewers you know all along
several of us have been saying we have
fixated on the wrong thing we were
calling this an achievement gap
when we should have been always framing
it as an opportunity gap right that is
that kids need the opportunity to learn
and and and that means once you frame it
that way then you start to look at the
conditions under which teaching and
learning occur
those conditions have been very uneven
and all our fixation on test scores has
never addressed that we never have made
sure for example that kids have access
to capable teachers that they're in
schools with lab equipment and
and uh libraries basic things that kids
need and now we have the issues of
access around online learning and again
if you're an affluent kid and something
is hard you can get a private tutor you
can go on to a khan academy
now hopefully khan academy's available
to everybody but there are a lot of kids
who don't have those resources and so
my hope is that policy makers will
become much more attentive to these gaps
in opportunity that are pervasive
throughout american society
i mean speaking about the opportunity
gap i couldn't agree more i mean you
know the digital divide is is the most
obvious one especially during covid when
you need that to just even be able to
access your potential but even outside
of covid if if you have even a handful
of kids in the classroom who don't have
internet access at home or proper
internet access the whole classroom is
not going to be able to take advantage
of personalized learning tools or
whatever else
and then you know i was surprised i
remember several months ago reading a
report that a majority of minority
majority schools don't even offer high
schools don't offer a lot of the courses
that we take for granted in high school
and when they do offer it they don't
cover it at the same level of rigor
because their expectations arguably
whatever something's going on they might
not be having the same level equipment
they might not be having
the same level of expertise among some
of the the faculty we don't know but
these kids aren't getting the
opportunity to even engage at that level
what do you see as the major levers you
know if you were secretary of education
or emperor of the universe what would
you do to help close that
well i think it has to go beyond
secretary of education i think um the
federal government state governments
should be leaning hard on the high-tech
companies these companies are the
richest companies in the world right now
and have gotten richer even during the
pandemic
you think about amazon facebook google
these companies are massive they're
large they have a social responsibility
to invest in the infrastructure that
allows access um if you think about it
telephone service um would not be
available in rural areas if we just saw
it as a cost we recognize that there's a
basic need and right to communication
and so therefore we do have cell towers
and telephone service even in the most
remote rural areas we need that kind of
a commitment to access
to basic services uh around the country
i think the federal government has to
lean in and we might need legislation
but we've got to figure out a way to
make that possible because it it not
only is it about learning opportunities
but as we know we rely on the internet
for everything now and uh to see so many
people cut off is i think again a
reflection of the
deep and persistent inequality in our
country
no
you're absolutely right and all of the
opportunity gaps that need to be filled
i mean the most obvious one especially
during covid is clearly the digital
divide and i mean any sense you know
we're signatories to this connect all
students campaign that common sense
media is doing and you know my back of
the envelope calculations are you could
connect all the families that aren't
connected in the whole country for one
percent of one of the rounds of stimulus
that where that were so it feels like
the most obvious
thing in the world to do and it
economically empowers people probably
even improves their health outcomes
because they'll get access to
information and and what and and and
whatnot what what's your view
um
from
how
what are teachers seeing and feeling and
how might you know do you think what
we're seeing in covid is it's just a
covert thing or do you think there's
certain aspects of teaching or schooling
that might be forever altered because of
what we're going through
i i i'm well i think i was just on a
call yesterday with some teachers in
texas to san antonio and many of them
their primary concern was the mental
health needs of kids
and the stress that they're seeing their
children under kids who are not going
outside kids who are um depressed and
and anxious because of the climate in
the country and
i'm worried about the long-term effects
and consequences of that
you also have the same kinds of uh
stress on teachers
just think about the teachers who are
juggling kids at home while it's
expected to do
zoom instruction so unfortunately when
you're preoccupied with those things how
do you get creative on the use of zoom
and online platforms to provide really
high quality instruction there are some
schools that are doing that they
provided the support and guidance to
teachers but i i think that that's not
happening nearly enough and and so what
we're seeing is many kids who get um
they're discouraged they're not
motivated they're burnt out from too
many hours online um and uh they're
giving up and that worries me especially
for the older students who should be
preparing for college right now
no that meant that makes a ton of sense
i mean what if you you know we're able
we have a lot of teachers who watch this
you know what's your
what would you tell them i mean as you
as you just described there's a lot of
stressors going on and and they're
trying to they're doing heroic efforts
what would you what advice would you
have for them to kind of you know
navigate all of this
i i would strongly encourage them to go
on to edutopia
um that's my favorite platform um
because they provide very practical
guidance
to teachers on first of all how do you
provide social and emotional support to
kids in an online medium how do you
design good lessons
k through 12 in a variety of subjects
for kids that can get kids engaged and
help kids to develop their skills and
and and ensure that learning is
occurring um so you need those kinds of
hands-on
tools available for teachers many
districts don't have the resources to
provide it so unfortunately it falls on
the back of teachers to figure out where
can i get the help i need but there's
help available there and i didn't really
encourage uh you to go check it out if
you're a teacher out there listening at
utopia i don't get paid so this is that
uh this is a free commercial uh i just
think it's no they're they're a
not-for-profit that's george lucas's um
and i'm i'm also a a very big fan of
them so so we're we're we're aligned
there what what do you are there going
to be
um some fallout i mean we've talked
about some of the
the negatives that are going to happen
over i mean frankly we're already
happening pre-covert and if anything
covid's making it worse around you know
opportunity gaps and digital divide
do you think that you know people have
you know obviously your traditional
standardized state assessments have had
to go on hold because of kovid
teach you know every teacher i talk to
they're thinking about how they use zoom
in a more interactive way
people are getting creative in terms of
breakout sessions you know use of things
like khan academy do you think that some
of this is going to
you know people right now are doing
hybrids where even if you know when they
are coming back to school there's going
to be some kids that are still home so
how do you support both do you think any
of that stuff is going to last post
covent or do you think we're just we're
going to go back to what we were doing
before
that's a good question and something
i've been thinking a lot about i think
ideally this disruption should serve as
an opportunity to do things differently
and hopefully better than we were before
that we don't just return to schools as
we knew them
for too many kids school was not a place
where they felt supported where they
felt stimulated and challenged we need
that to be the primary focus if if you
think about it uh and i just did a
conversation with the former secretary
of education a few days ago no child
behind got as fixated on achievement as
measured by test scores
which then directed teachers to
prepare kids for tests
uh that to me was such an uh a
disservice to education because what we
know is that teaching when it's powerful
should be creative it should uh be
stimulating it should be engaging it
should uh be meaningful uh and you know
as a former teacher myself i taught in
providence rhode island when i first
started uh i taught history and i loved
history
and i knew then that my job was not
simply to cover the textbook my job was
to make history come to life so that
students would appreciate and and want
to learn more history and that's the
message i often tell teachers you know
we know we're doing it right when kids
want more right that's the way knowledge
works you want more once you start to
realize the power of knowledge well
that's what we've got to come back to
we've got to redirect the attention of
our teachers their job should be to get
kids excited about learning to focus on
motivation to focus on making it
meaningful
rather than simply covering material and
assessing to see if kids got it that
that to me was um i mean i get it we
needed the evidence the kids were
learning we just focused on the wrong
things
and you feel that you know post cover
there might be some opportunities to
rethink this because some of the
traditional kind of testing structures
have at least had they've been paused in
some of the state assessments
and and also in this ess
every student succeeds we've replaced
nordstrom behind give states more
flexibility to do things differently to
do formative assessments and
performance-based assessment so we don't
have to allow the assessment itself to
be the driving factor but what i see is
that in several states
i don't see the vision or the knowledge
about how to do things differently and
that worries me if you look at the
independent schools they're already
doing it differently
many of the affluent public schools are
where we see the problems is in the
schools serving low-income kids which
are over half the kids of the in the
country today that's where we see the
kind of kill and drill approach
um that i think leaves many kids
alienated
no makes sense so we have a question
here from a teacher christina espinoza
good day dr nogueira i am a teacher in
the sweetwater union high school school
or high school district currently we are
teaching 100 virtually and serving
students from extremely diverse
backgrounds since we see students
through throughout several zip codes
from a rather fluent east chula vista
all the way down to the border we cannot
have a one-size-fits-all grading policy
how from your experience should we
approach grading
good question and
hello to the folks down sweetwater they
have literally hundreds of kids i think
each day who at least when schools were
open were coming across the border to go
to school some kids getting up at three
in the morning to get to school so just
want to acknowledge um
the the efforts of those kids and the
educators who serve them
i think grading all along and i've been
uh struggling with this as a university
professor for many years
you know the the what we forget is the
real learning is not in the grade you
earn it's in your ability to demonstrate
how much you've learned it's the work
you produce right so we should be using
grading to give feedback to students
meaningful feedback on how to improve
and we should be treating work as um
in an iterative manner that is the real
learning that occurs through the
revision right
of getting it getting it right or
getting it improving upon the finished
product and so uh what what always has
concerns about the way we do grading in
schools is kids get fixated on the grade
some kids want the a and so they'll aim
for the a some kids just want to pass
and what we should be more concerned
about is the learning how much have they
learned what do they what can they share
with us and demonstrate as proof of what
they've learned that's what we should be
looking at and that's what it's a degree
that we need to fix a grade at the end
we should grade
evidence of growth evidence of mastery
because when we don't focus on that what
we end up with is kids who are pushed
along grade by grade who have a weak
foundation who can't do very much end up
in college can't write can't do research
even though they passed and that is a
huge problem
i couldn't agree more you know one of
the things that i talk a lot about is
70 of kids that show up at community
college have to take remedial math which
you know is not a euphemism for 11th or
12th grade math it's pre-algebra it's
6th or 7th grade math so the whole
system to your point year after year
kids promoted they get 20 wrong on
dividing decimals they get 30 wrong on
exponents those gaps just keep
accumulating at some point the algebra
is hard they start watering it down for
them so that they have the illusion of
progress you get to college and they're
saying you're not even ready to learn
algebra yet which is really a 9th or
10th grade subject
and those kids all of them are capable
because we get letters from them every
day when they go back and fill in their
gaps they're all capable of it but it's
incredibly disheartening and we know
that's like the
that's the weeder
or the best predictor of not succeeding
in college is having to show up and
having to take non-credit-bearing
remedial courses
you know i mean with that lens how do
you see
and and everything that we do at khan
academy is is trying to facilitate
mastery learning so i love your your
view there but what's your um sense of
college you know there's a question from
youtube hari abru do you think college
will change in the future because of the
pandemic
ah college is gonna have to change and
the main thing has to change is the cost
you know it's out of reach for too many
people we have too many students that
have to take on debts that they'll you
know incur
and and be paying back well into
adulthood um because the the cost of
college has gone too too high um so
we've got to figure out how to reduce
cost how to increase access but also how
to improve teaching so it's very easy
you know we often um in the
conversations about teaching and the
critiques we focus on k-12 but i would
say some of the worst teaching i see is
at the university level where the
primary mode of teaching is still
lecture
and and lecture um
even if you're a very good lecturer
is not the most effective way for
students to learn something
we need to know um real get the evidence
again evidence-based teaching is much
more interactive uh let me just use one
example going back to math and algebra
that you gave when i was in eighth grade
uh i took algebra with uh my teacher mrs
harris in in in new york city and miss
paris uh started class by saying you
kids are lucky because i'm the best
teacher in the school
she said tell me who out there in this
class struggles in math and very
sheepishly i raised my hand because i
was finding arithmetic but algebra was
uh had thrown me uh for uh for a loop so
she said you kids are gonna sit in front
because i'm gonna check on you
throughout
the day and every day to make sure
you're with me because she understood
that if you didn't get it in september
you certainly wouldn't have it by june
she was constantly looking at her work
she wanted proof that we got it she was
inviting our questions
not to embarrass us but to make sure
that we were with her it was interactive
and because of that i came out of that
course much more confident about my
knowledge and understanding of math when
we teach that way
in that kind of interactive way when we
recognize that teaching and learning are
connected and account academy does this
better than i think most people then
what teach learning becomes uh an
exercise in in in acquiring and becoming
and getting ownership of the
information material the skills uh
instead of a passive experience of
sitting through lessons and that i think
is the biggest change at both the
university and at the k-12 level that we
need to bring about
no it's fascinating because you know
these days you're in covid with everyone
learning on video conference everyone's
like how do we make it engaging because
kids are going on a different window
video
windows and you know and everyone's
saying yeah you got to ask them
questions you got to be on top of them
you got to pull them out of the screen
put them into breakouts and but you know
it's always like but you know by the way
that's also a good idea when you're in a
physical classroom exactly and your
point about your point about mastery
learning it sounds like you had a great
teacher who intuitively
got that you can't let these kids have
the gaps because
it becomes a self-fully self-fulfilling
prophecy if if you don't know how to
dribble you can practice free throws all
day you're not going to be a great
basketball player uh but somehow you
know the the system you know and i i
don't blame the system because it's you
know it's the best way we knew how to do
it 200 years ago but there's now
wait anyway
to your point your teacher was able to
do it with pretty low tech so maybe we
could have done it a little bit
different
and think about a while ago i'm the best
teacher and best teacher her meant not
that she taught the best kids
best teacher meant she could teach all
kinds of kids see and that's also a
shift in the way we think about teaching
there are a lot of people out there who
think they're good but they're only good
with kids who don't need help
they only want to teach honors they only
want to teach ap they don't want to
teach kids who struggle and that's part
of the problem that you know real
teaching is about helping to make it
accessible make it um uh get it help
kids to get it so i think the shift
needs to occur on both ends in how we
deliver but also how we how we engage
students if i could just use one analogy
if you watch kids when they're playing a
video game
a new game
if they need help they don't get it they
go on youtube they call a friend
that's part of learning
then they're making mistakes because
that's part of learning too you learn
through your mistakes and then they
advance they advance because they get
better and better and then they master
the game
that's the way learning occurs for kids
and that's what we should be replicating
in our classrooms a version of that
i couldn't agree more that's you know
that's what we aspired exactly to to
help facilitate here's a good question
here from youtube nish786 uh you're
widely known for your work on equity
race and poverty issues in education how
do you see social emotional learning
fitting into those areas
if schools aren't addressing racism they
aren't fully addressing trauma in quotes
how can schools better align their work
in these related areas
so you know one of the things we've
known all teachers know this kids learn
through relationships
kids will learn from teachers they know
care about them who are invested in them
and caring doesn't mean we have to be
best buddies uh my teacher miss harris
wasn't my best buddy she let me know
that if you're in my class you're gonna
learn you're gonna work right she was a
warm demander
racism gets in the way of that because
it often results in lowered expectations
it results in strained relationships uh
and and sometimes you it results in
teachers who don't see themselves as as
being invested in the learner taking
responsibility for whether or not their
students are actually learning so
uh um i think it's important that we we
we have an equity mindset um and we
recognize that
professional educators have a
moral and professional responsibility to
educate all their students right and if
they can't they need to let someone know
i've got a kid in my class who's not
learning and they need to call for help
to do anything less in my opinion is a
form of malpractice and um and and
teachers should not be complicit in
allowing kids not to learn
when you see kids end up in high school
or college who haven't learned basic
math that means they were educators all
along the way who saw it and did nothing
and what advice would you you know i
think everyone agrees intellectually but
if you know you can imagine a you're a
ninth grade teacher you have five kids
in your class that are you know barely
struggling you kind of water it down for
them they barely you know scratch by on
a c you know that they're not they're
gonna be those kids who have to take
remedial math if they even get to
through high school and get to college
but you know that teacher's feeling like
hey there's 30 kids here i got to do
what i can i told the administration the
administration's kind of
you know saying look that's the way life
is like how does someone re you know
from from a teacher's point of view or
is it does it have to happen at a
systemic level how do we make sure that
that you know that there are ways to
support those kids
you know truthfully it's hard for a
teacher by themselves to affect
system change right they can change
what's happening in their classroom they
can create the climate in their
classroom where kids feel supported and
engaged um and they and you know the
truth is and uh that when the classroom
door closes the teachers have a lot of
power uh at least when we're in a
physical space together um but to bring
about real system change you need
leaders principals superintendents who
understand that we've got to become
better at intervening early with kids
better at at providing you know some
kids as you know sal need more time than
the traditional school day allows so we
need to find ways to create more time as
well for the for kids on subjects that
take more time to for them to learn
yeah it's always blown my mind that slow
is equated with dumb when oftentimes the
kids just need a little more time
they're they're really trying to
internalize it and and and if they have
a strong foundation they're going to
race we see that at khan academy all the
time in our own data so i couldn't agree
with you more that that that equation is
really flawed and it makes kids even
think that they're not smart when
they're fully capable you know one of
the attributes that kids most frequently
cite as being valuable to them from a
teacher is patience
you know teachers who are patient and
giving them the chance and teachers who
are organized
now i remember when i was tutoring my
cousins i mean i tell the story all the
time that when i first made some of
those videos for them uh they told me
famously that they like me better on
youtube than in person and you know i i
think part of it and i always try to
parse what they were saying because they
weren't saying they really appreciated
having me as like a a real person who
was invested in them but i think the
video comment was really about the
patience that they they they didn't feel
the pressure to learn it right in that
three minutes that they could come back
to it etc they had multiple options
and then to pick it up again you know
that's because again that's how we learn
and we all we don't all learn at the
same pace
no couldn't agree more so you know the
time we have left any you know we have
teachers watching this we have students
we have a lot of parents and obviously
everyone's got a certain level of
anxiety these days above and beyond what
they normally would have had you know
what advice do you have about where
education is going how people should
navigate it you know any big takeaways
yeah i'd say right now we have to um use
again use this disruption to start
thinking about what kind of schools do
we want to create what kind of
classrooms do we want to create start
visualize what the end should look like
you know imagine schools where kids were
excited about learning where they were
happy to come each day what would it
take to create those kinds of schools
and let's start planning for that place
heart planning schools where
relationships are valued where we are
thinking holistically about the needs of
kids the academic the social the
emotional needs of kids because they're
all integrated and let's start thinking
about how to really organize schools to
meet the needs of our students if we did
that then i think we would end up with
very different schools than we have now
no couldn't agree more and what i always
stress is you know people view me as a
technologist but i don't view myself
that way i always say
never use technology for technology's
sake always think about what is the goal
and
99
of the time the best possible resource
is an amazing in-person teacher for your
child and if technology can help unlock
what that teacher can do personalize
more fill in gaps mastery learning then
that's all good but technology has to be
in service to the humans and in service
of those goals
absolutely i agree i couldn't agree more
well well uh dean aguero thank you so
much for joining i mean this is one of
those conversations i think we could
continue for another several hours but
i'll let you go for now uh but but thank
you so much for joining this is really
valuable and so i want to thank you for
the service you provide to kids
throughout the country in making um
education and knowledge more accessible
and um i i think you you provided just a
tremendous resource to so many so thank
you
no well it's a lot more than me but i
really appreciate that and i'm going to
follow up with you i think there's ways
that we can work together
that would be great
all the best great yep thank you
thank you so uh thanks everyone
thanks everyone uh as always uh you know
dino guerra was really great um and i
wish we had another you know five hours
to chat because this is obviously a
really big subject but hopefully you all
got as much out of that as as i did uh
thanks for joining uh just a couple of
announcements we're gonna have um
my next uh
live stream
well actually i i was on this document
that i was looking at but now it
disappeared uh but we're gonna have that
webinar with um our chief learning
officer uh i believe it is oh there it
goes all right uh on uh seven tips for
motivating middle school and high
school's kids during distance learning
this is going to be october 22nd 4 p.m
pacific time i highly recommend it
you're going to really enjoy kristen
she's our chief learning officer not
only does she know almost everything to
know about learning science uh but she's
also really
really engaging so so i think y'all will
really enjoy that that webinar uh so
with that i will see y'all uh at the
next uh the next homeroom live stream
talk to y'all later
you